bienvenue aujourd'hui pour cette vidéo
on voit faire un truc un peu pas comme
d'habitude puisque on l a vu deux ans à
faire des trucs assez sérieux sur scène
soit pour aujourd'hui je vous propose de
faire un truc à l'acccusée puis ce qu'on
va aller faire un jeu sur internet un
jeu qui s'appelle le lieu ni persol po
clipse et vous allez voir en fait c'est
un jeu qui est vachement intéressant
avec ce ne sera pas forcément content ça
a l'air d'être un jeu où il suffit de
cliquer sur des boutons de prime abord
et budget en fait c'est juste de faire
des piper clip c'est à dire des
trombones donc c'est un jour une plage /
train de commencer à voler voilà je fais
mon premier pétard clip j'espère que
c'est le premier d'une longue série
et voilà donc petit à petit j'ai fait
mes piper clip ça suffit d'appuyer sur
un bouton pour créer durant plus de peur
clip et le décès de s'imaginer qu'on a
une intelligence artificielle et voilà
on a une machine
il nous a dit faites des peurs climat
plutôt fera mieux ce sera donc notre
objectif c'est vraiment de maximiser le
nombre de pays possible surtout une
première chose dont on se rend compte
assez vite c'est que en fait on a un
budget
v le bol funds alors ce moment j'ai
quatre dollars c'est frêche mais en
sorte que déjà avec l'argent on va
pouvoir faire mieux par exemple faire du
marketing vous voir faire du
manufacturing s'est effectué en fait on
pourra construire une usine et j'imagine
que si on peut faire une usine pourra
produire beaucoup plus de beaucoup plus
de trombone donc une bonne stratégie sur
l'intelligence artificielle c'est
peut-être ça décide d'abord de faire
suffisamment d'argent pour pouvoir
ensuite construire une usine alors là ça
va prendre beaucoup de temps à ce jeu il
est super lent et ultra addictif
du coup au fait j'ai passé pas mal de
temps et une jouer et du coup forcément
y avoir quelques petites que terre et je
vous raconterai pas tout ce qui se passe
dans le jeu mais il serait de contrer
les moments importants du jeu ce cas
d'un point de vue moral des yeux est ce
qu'il ya des très très intéressant ok
j'en suis à la première était un peu du
jeu j'ai fini de fouiller tout le fil en
fête et du coup j'ai pu de quoi faire
des trombones heureusement maintenant il
ya des nouvelles options qui sont
apparus avec des combinés sur le russe
aussi d'y avoir complété chirurgie c'est
à dire les ressources de calcul donc
quelque part là je commençais à pouvoir
vraiment faire de lire une certaine
manière la gts entraîné qu'il n'y a un
peu débile qui cliquaient sur un butin
vous voyez que j'ai atteint les 1000
clip c'est au bout de cinq minutes 25
voilà notre 4,6 et encore juste le début
ok j'ai avancé un petit peu dans le jeu
est maintenant en proposant un truc que
je trouve assez énorme voilà pourquoi
refaire tour plus d'argent il ya tout
est stratégie marketing et tout ça alors
je rajouter un petit son marketing si ça
ça me permet de vendre toujours plus de
trombone et faire plus d'argent pour
pouvoir produire encore plus de dons
bonne semaine sur une logique les
capitalistes mais en fait on sent qu'il
ya j'en ai rien à [ __ ] que ce soit
capté sinon moi tout ce que je veux
c'est faire plus de trombone et pour
faire plus de trombone à et il faut
avoir plus d'argent pour faire plus
d'usinés du coup il faut faire de
l'argent et du coup ça vaut le coup
d'investir dans le marketing mais bref
il ya un truc encore un peu plus
bizarres qui s'appelle le hypno harmonix
voilà je vais pouvoir trouver des
certaine fréquence normale
tout ça pour dire que voilà j'ai cette
option hypno harmonix est gelée cliquez
dessus et ça va me permettre de
complètement changer le comportement des
utilisateurs
on sent tout de suite que pour unia la
voilà c'est fait je viens d'avoir un
impact fondamental sur toute la société
humaine en cliquant sur un bouton tout
seul pour faire toujours plus de
trombone pourquoi parce que des humains
qui veulent acheter mais trombone ça me
fait
dur plus d'argent qui va opérer qui va
pouvoir être réinvestis pour construire
toujours plus d'usinés pour pouvoir
construire toujours plus deux trombones
et ça c'est ma stratégie optimale
si j'ai envie de maximiser le nombre de
trombone sur terre ok j'ai un petit peu
avancer dans le jeu je fais un petit
pont puisque j'ai dépassé maintenant les
2 millions de trombone 2 millions
d'euros dès 2011
ça va super vite c'est ça découle et
tout d'un coup tu parce que j'ai eu les
méga clippers là donc c'est d'aimer gaz
usine donc pour faire des super plumes
bonne et ce qui est vraiment important à
noter c'est que avant je produisais avec
mélusine je produisais jeu pas quelques
centaines de trombone par seconde
et là j'en suis à plus de 100 fois plus
je suis à 18000 trombone par seconde ça
ça donne vraiment une idée de l'
explosion exponentielle
c'est vraiment le truc ressortir encore
et encore dans ce jeu c'est que avant
lille trombone c'était beaucoup émanant
mythomane c'est vraiment trop froid rien
et en fait si on y réfléchit
en fait en ce moment le but n'est pas de
temps de faire des trombones confère des
trombones c c'est sûr que c'est
l'objectif final du jeu mais c'est pas
tellement nos objectifs maintenant
kouassi dit y réfléchir vraiment là ce
dont j'ai vraiment besoin c'est juste
d'avoir toujours plus du sinn pour
fabriquer toujours plus de choses là je
vais avoir un truc
les histoires de deux ordinateurs
quantiques à grand chose ça va avec ce
que je connais de l'amitié une critique
et d informatique et d'informatique
quantique
mais avec ces histoires de ces repentis
je peux avoir toujours plus d'opérations
qui pour plus de calcul qui permet de
créer de nouvelles idées nous ayons tout
ça possible creativity qui en parallèle
et tout ça mais en fait c'est très très
lié dans le jeu et ça permet d'avoir pu
voir ces améliorations incroyable des
performances que l'on attendait méga
piper de ses producteurs d'oeufs
des trombones et ça c'est une leçon
assez générales en fait si demain jean
est d'atteindre un tel objectif est que
je suis une super intelligence non ma
priorité ça va pas est de produire le
truc en question ça va être d'abord
d'investir dans les technologies qui
vont me permettre ensuite de produire
très rapidement en très grande quantité
en très grands volumes
les différents bien que j'ai envie de
produire doit à l'excès c'est assez
intéressant à travers ce lieu de voir
que des objectifs qui n'ont pas l'air
d'être l'objectif initial surgissent
naturellement et deviennent en fait ce
qu'on appelle des intervalles des
objectifs parce qu'on veut être un
instrument d'autres et je l'envoie vers
l'ex en vidéo de monsieur fille qui en a
parlé lors ce qui est venu à le pfl ce
qui est intéressant de voir ses côtés un
truc que je déjà faire maintenant mais
il ya d'autres trucs que je peux encore
faire mais ça viendra il faut plus de
you me mets à cesser les autres le pont
du concert soigner le cancer dans le
monde ce qu'il fallait gagner en fait du
trust donc les humains vont plus me
faire confiance et je avoir accès à plus
de centres de données pour faire des
calculs et pareil je pourrai plus d'or
peut-être que je vais plus tard résoudre
le problème de la paix dans le monde et
le problème du réchauffement climatique
voilà ce sont des problèmes dans tout
cas dans ce jeu qui peuvent être mots
qui d'après ce pourrait être résolue par
des solutions technologiques
donc c'est un peu difficile de dire si
en vrai ce sera vraiment le cas mais ce
qui me semble clairement évident c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
progrès qui pourront être faites dans
tous ces domaines pour la paix dans le
monde est pas si évident voici à son
charge peut-être que ce sera plus facile
de garantir la paix dans le monde mais
typiquement sa perte indirecte par
exemple produire plus pour permettre à
voir des processus de création de
nourriture finalement parce que ce qu'on
veut c'est vraiment qu'il a une voiture
pour tout le monde parce que souvent la
famine est une des cause une des causes
récurrentes de
les guerres si on est capable d'avoir
des processus de création de nourriture
qu'ils soient qui sont implémentés bhl
très facilement par par tout le monde et
qui utilise un million de ressources
naturelles ça pourrait fortement
contribué à la peine au monde tous ses
fans je pense que vraiment le technology
ont vraiment quelque chose à apporter et
il faut mais ça viendra pas tout seul il
faut vraiment faire de la recherche dans
ces domaines pour pouvoir résoudre ces
grands problèmes de nos sociétés
donc j'ai un peu avancer dans le jeu on
me propose maintenant de relâcher des
hypno de drones s'était d'ailleurs à
priori des drones qui vont hypnotisé
tous les humains voir ce que ça va
donner je clique sur le bouton
que s'est il passé tu perdu et truc que
j'avais il ya un truc qui me reste à
appuyer qui s'appelle tough tubules elf
holdings inc signe technique pour
rassembler des clips making technologie
qui est peu clip ce que ça permettra de
prendre des peppers clip et parce que là
on les fabrique et met on faisait pas
grand chose avec
et là on va pouvoir combiner ces pprt
pour pouvoir fabriquer des trucs à
brec'h donc je clique sur ce bouton
qu'est ce qui se passe maintenant
à grand chose c'est passe-t-il à falloir
maintenant à power wind et ça va venir
our grid
maintenant je peux fabriquer ma propre
énergie et en fait là je suis en train
de passer dans la seconde phase du jeu
ou en gros je vais devoir m'occuper moi
même de fabriquer mon énergie et en
particulier maintenant je vais pouvoir
lancer dans la nature des drones qui
vont faire qui on s'occupait de tout
pour moi donc notamment des after the
woods qui vont aller chercher
directement le matériel de base est
essentiellement dû faire ou des
matériaux des métaux nécessaires pour
fabriquer ensuite des trombones donc et
un autre truc qui ne sert que c'est laid
wired rhône ce qui vont transformer
cette matière brute en des fils qui ne
pourra ensuite être utilisés par les
clips factory jeunes arrivent jusque là
bientôt
donc voilà en fait là maintenant il ya
plus d'argent en jeu l'argent a disparu
puisqu'il ya plus de d'humains donc on
n'a pas besoin de s'occuper d'argent et
en fait on est en gros seul sur terre
maintenant on est libre et on a du
matériel sur terre pour voir fabriquer
un maximum de trombone et donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait on produit on va chercher nos
matériaux nos ressources primaires onu
on va exploiter l'énergie solaire parce
que c'est plus grosse forme d'énergie
qui la principale énergique donc sur
terre on va exploiter en imagine qu'en
fait le soleil c'est un peu notre
nouveau réacteur thermonucléaire avec
lequel on va pouvoir utiliser cette
énergie pour faire ce qu'on veut et
navals dans nos usines pour fabriquer
directement des trombones et on peut
réutiliser à chaque fois c'est trombone
donc là on a les news de cliffs
c'est ce qu'on peut utiliser pour
ensuite faire plus de drones et plus de
choses qui vont permettre notamment
maintenant essayer de faire plus de
drones plus de plus de factory pour
pouvoir maximiser le nombre de trombone
et et pour cela avoir besoin de deux
fermes solaires de batterie et tout ça
et voilà j'ai un petit peu avancé dans
cette deuxième phase en fête du jeu en
ligne europe au clip sous cette menace
n'a plus des humains et ont fait que
l'on fait tout avec des drones
et avec l'énergie solaire tout seul et
on plutôt tout seul et ce qui est assez
impressionnant c'est que ça change
complètement le nombre de trombone que
l'on produit était à quelques centaines
de millions avant cela et là on en est à
triengen en anglais qui veut dire des
millions de milliards aux français mais
bref
là on a vraiment dépassé de 10 puissance
dépasser de 10 puissance 8 à 10
puissance 14
c'est un changement d'échelle c'est ça
c'est assez intéressant à noter parce
que voilà il ya de bonnes chances que la
progression des technologies ça marche
pendant un temps par un une espèce de
paille et quand le kiki complètement une
percée technologique un changement de
paradigme et technologiques nouvelles y
très très très bonne idée ou juste un
truc qu'on peut tout à coup faire parce
qu'on a accès à telle ou telle puissance
de calcul mais tel le telle façon de
faire qui va complètement changer
voilà ce qu'on veut on parle parfois de
tippingpoint et donc il ya quand même de
bonnes choses qui est ce genre de
tippingpoint y fasse
pourrait-on changer l'échelle du
problème auquel on était en train de
penser avant ceux là où ça devient du
sérieux les gens là le nombre de zéros
est juste incroyable
en fait j'ai des coupeurs nom de ses
nombreux absolument chine au texte
qu'ils ont paris 6-2 au petit lion au
petit l'yonne en fait en anglais en
français ça serait pas optimale
quelle technique marc normalement en
français ça fait millions milliards
milieu biglione et puis après milliards
en france est normand il ya billon
billiard prions trillard cuadrilla ne
doit être au tour de quad rayon quoi
david ya tu casses et en termes de
puissance du 10 puissance beaucoup aux 3
6 12 15 18 21 points 4 7 10 puissance 27
et ce qui est vrai en pousse et qu'on
approche les 5 x 10 puissance 27 on va y
arriver
la tension cinq a321 pas prononcé à 5
oct tillon 5 x 10 puissance 27 c'est
juste énorme et en fait on est en train
d'être simplement d'épuiser le nombre de
là les ressources naturelles de la
planète ce qui est assez fou et c'est
vraiment le temps qui nous a fallu deux
jours pour y arriver
alors bien sûr je vais très accéléré par
rapport à la réalité mais voilà au début
au plaisir un trombone à la fois est en
fête avec ses développements
technologiques
voilà la croissance est vraiment très
très rapide et un havre est en
décroissance qui sont caractéristiques
de la croissance exponentielle de tentes
en rajoute zéro derrière alors je me
demande si c'est même pas ça serait
peut-être même un peu plus que
exponentielle ici ça va peut-être une
croissan ce super exponentielle
l'analyse en cours du temps et peuvent
faire ça mais ça décuple très très très
vite et il se pourrait bien si ça ne
paraît pas du tout ça me paraît assez
crédible personnellement que le progrès
des technologies soient un peu d'eux
mêmes c'est à dire que très rapidement
l'espace de très peu de temps la
quantité de ce qu'on fait ne cesse de
doubler voire de c'est le temps qu'il
faut pour doubler ne cesse d'être de
plus en plus court donc quelqu'un on a
vraiment sur deux explosions
seulement faramineuses là on approche
vraiment du goût du bout du bout on va
avoir utilisé tout la matière sur terre
sur terre c'est comme un moment
incroyable a plus que 5 secondes 4 3 2 1
et ouf il ya plus rien sur terre le
nombre de piper cub ça on est quasiment
à 6 au petit lait
c'est ci soient disponibles et il ya un
truc qui m'est proposé à maintenant que
j'ai 128 opération suffisamment
d'énergie est suffisamment de pepper
clip de trombone cespc exploration on va
démonter tout tout tout ce que ce que
sur terre et expand fameux galaxy spica
univers unis va aller ça passe pour la
phase iii pas été résolu
[Musique]
alors que se passe-t-il maintenant alors
ce que je peux faire c'est lancer des
pubs dans l'univers en fait on va faire
en fait de l'exploration spatiale pour
pouvoir récupérer du matériel ferchaud
objectivement comme toi c'est pas
conquérir l'univers une car l'univers
sus un moyen pour atteindre dauphin et
la faim ici l'objectif vraiment c'est de
faire un maximum de trombone et vu qu'on
est des études et ou matériels sur terre
on peut pas progresser sur tard par
contre si on parle dans l'espace et ben
on peut réussir à toujours plus de
ressources
on est parti à la conquête de l'espace
maintenant et on utilise notamment
descendent de von neumann 5 rose est une
super vidéo de peel s & space time sur
cession de balle de match c'était un
design conçu froid qui inspire aux pets
des réplicateurs de renault m dont
j'avais parlé dans un tas de pâte et
l'excellent saclay l'idée c'est voilà
vous voulez conquérir l'univers
alors si vous pouvez faire c'est
d'envoyer une sonde c'est mal parti
ce que vous voulez en fait plus faire
c'est envoyer de petits approuvé les
tout petits parce que quand vous a
envoyé plus soit plein de petites
secondes aux quatre coins de l'univers
ça ça marche beaucoup mieux mais ce qui
marchera encore mieux c'est ce qui nous
a fait si vous faites des maisons qui se
grattent de s'auto répliqué son appel
des sondes de bono man et c'est vraiment
là l'idée du truc
donc là je suis en train d'essayer de le
chine avait plein de son oeuvre en
espérant que normalement ça va avoir su
ce qui va se répliquer suffisamment et
c'est vraiment typique et des
croissances exponentielles voilà depuis
le début c'est décolle pas parce que les
sur l'appliqué pas assez vite et mauvais
trop facilement c'est comme la sélection
naturelle c'est que quand il ya le truc
meurent avant de s'appliquer basse a
fini par disparaître rapidement
il ya ce qu'il faut faire c'est faire en
sorte bon sens pas mal de probe et
surtout en faisant en sorte qu'ils vont
bien sûr ce taux appliqué et qui vont
être à ses résidents et
ne pas mourir avant de sauter ok si on
arrive à avoir ces deux trucs là on va
avoir une population qui va se montrer
croître et sont tous trois être de façon
collective nécessairement du coup
croître de façon exponentielle et du
coup là vraiment une des chances de
conquérir tout l'univers
d'ailleurs ça c'est intéressant parce
que c'est pas du tout s'y pique ajuste
ses histoires de son ont de bonnes
vannes c'est en fait vous êtes une
intelligence artificielle
la première chose à faire pour atteindre
pour être sûr d'atteindre notre objectif
c'est vraiment il faut se répliquer et
avoir plein de versions de soi même
parce que si on n'est qu'une seule
version de soi même et que ou meurs
baloji final on est sûr de pas pouvoir
d'influencé alors que si on ya plein de
copies de nous même si on a une des
copies qui meurt il ya encore un moyen
de l'influencé de faire en sorte que
l'objectif final soit atteint aussi bien
que possible
c'est en train de partir en cacahuète
puisque mais von neumann prob mais son
de von neumann sont en train de
batailler en gare intergalactique contre
des drifters que je patrouille qui sont
ces gens oui bleus me sont méchant ils
détruisent mais son de vote de man du
coup maintenant il faut combattre et
conquérir la galaxie avec notion de von
neumann du cac après une longue période
de gros stagnation ou atteint donc les
laissons de son pipeline qui
n'atteignent pas mal de planète
consommaient beaucoup de du sinn avec
beaucoup de drones et tout ça mais
maintenant ça y est on est dans une
phase où la croissance d'une de pepper
clip taher repris de plus belle et
extrêmement vite et au plus vite lorsque
qu'on se mettait sur terre là la
répression sélection sociale est en
train de repartir à m6 pour 100g tous
ont visité 0%
pour cent de l'univers on approche de la
fin
comme vous l'a dit pas peu de temps
après avoir les premiers pourcentages
visibles les premiers milliardième de
pourcentage visible de en termes 2% de
venir explorer là je viens de te
dépasser le 1 % de l'univers explorer et
ça continue d'augmenter
bientôt je vous propose de vivre
ensemble la fin de ce jeu que je vais
bientôt avoir exploré tout l'univers et
c'est complètement tout quand vous y
pensez il était parti d'une machine
faire des trombones un art puis après on
a pris un auto clip pour faire les
vitrines tout seul et pierre on n'a pas
arrêté de se développer à trouver
toujours plus de technologie pour
pouvoir récupérer d'abord beaucoup
d'argent parce que c'était au début
c'était important d'avoir beaucoup
d'argent pour pouvoir
utiliser les services des humains mais
ensuite après il fait se débarrasser des
humains pour pouvoir aller plus loin et
vraiment tout automatisé à partir de
drones notamment et avoir une
consommation énergétique optimisée
production énergétique également qu'il y
était haute et optimisé et puis petit à
petit voilà on a fini par exploiter
toutes les ressources naturelles se
heurtèrent et vu que l'objectif c'est de
faire un maximum de trombone bas l'étape
suivante forcément c'était l'exploration
spatiale c'était à les utiliser toutes
les ressources de tout l'univers pour
faire tousser trombone et du coup on
s'est mis à explorer l'univers on a vu
que la meilleure façon de faire ça de
façon très efficace en fait c'est
surtout utilisé les sondes de von
neumann auto replicate risque d'avoir
pas mal aussi de faire en sorte que
l'auto réplication aille très vite pour
que on est une conquête exponentielle le
nombre de deux sons de clown est
exponentielle maintenant il est de
l'ordre de 10,7 noni lieu denis dionne
ce qui est mille fois plus que nombre de
trombone qu'on avait sur terre c'est
complètement fou et je maintenant grâce
à cette croissance exponentielle le
nombre de deux trombones qu'on a produit
au total la c5 cette décision'' si je me
trompe pas ça fait quelque chose de
l'ordre de 10 puissance 54 cd nombre
vraiment
une grosse proportion de l'univers
observable en fait dehors là maintenant
je suis à 50% de l'univers observable
ce qui est très important à noter c'est
que ça veut pas dire que ça fait la
moitié de ceux qui a affaire aux en
termes temporels notamment ben ali suite
j'y suis j'y vais 99% en fait on ne rien
voir 50% de l'univers et ce nombre
continue à augmenter alors rapproché des
100% dans la 90% 92 93 94 96 17 19
c'est fini et là j'ai un message de
l'amphore du trift qui est greetings
équipe mais curd va voir ce que ça dit
everything we were in you fields the
peak qui a deux fins possibles de ce jeu
soit j'accepte de tout recommencer dans
un nouveau bonheur c'est une soit je dis
non et je préfère éliminer tous les
tarifs tu une fois pour toute c'est ce
que je vais faire
donc voilà j'ai conquis vraiment tout
l'univers nombre de pepper clip ça
maintenant saturé c'est en décidant ce
qui fait donc à peu près 10 854
il reste plus de matière plus rien sauf
que je démantèle maintenant les drones
qui est monté aussi les foules et les
usines démontrent les ordinateurs
quantiques peu de puissance par des
raclées d'ordinateurs quantiques là
c'est bon là il reste encore 100 wire à
faire il faut les faire à la main
puisque à plus de machines pour les
faire aller
allez
et derniers moments de l'histoire de
l'univers j'espère que vous les trouvez
ça paie solennel c'est un peu un grand
moment dans l'histoire de l'univers que
le dernier trombone bout
l'univers soul punk lips et game un jeu
de franck lente un excellent joueur très
intéressant qui finit avec donc 37 7 30
septembre d'isilon certaines décisions
de pepper clip de trombone c'est un peu
triste en cette fin de l'univers
là des enfants n'a pas
scénario catastrophe causée par une
intelligence artificielle et allah nous
demande aussi ces scénarios sont inédits
ils ont été remontés par mois ou si j'ai
eu différentes inspirations à penser que
je suis l'auteur de ces différentes
histoires mais je vais beaucoup beaucoup
d'inspiration
vraiment j'ai eu d'élection conseil de
discussions avec certains clubs de mon
labo comment ces aides et alex et pour
la quatrième histoire avec ces histoires
de l'hypothèse de riemann en fait ça
vient de là conseil de thibault giroud
d'achat ce qui est bien sûr j'ai été
inspiré par beaucoup de films et de
séries dont les images apparaît c'est
justement dans la vidéo précédente
romain benoît demande s'il ne suffira
pas d'avoir une vérification manuelle de
ce que fait l'intelligence artificielle
est ce qui ne suffirait pas pardon de
faire en sorte que le gouvernement est
tout bleu encore tous les droits sur
intelligence artificielle et alors où
techniquement oui il y a moyen d'avoir
un contrôle manuel sur ce que fait un
tour ça artificiel après tout une
excellence artificiel c'est juste un
bout de code du coup il suffit de lire
le code des assurances artificielle
j'imagine le gros problème c'est que
bien sûr ce qu elle est incroyablement
longs et fait des milliards de lignes de
code ainsi c'est un nid adultes de
quelques gigaoctets qu il comprendre un
milliard de lignes de code en fait c'est
pas un pack qui est spécifique à notre
agence artificiel aujourd'hui essayer de
comprendre par exemple fonctionnement de
windows
c'est ultra difficile pas parce que
windows est incroyablement intelligent
mais juste parce que c'est un truc ultra
longs et là pour le coup windows c'est
un truc qui va être certifié validé mise
en production par des ingénieurs qui
sont experts du domaine mais ça empêche
pas le fait que dans windows il puisse y
avoir des bugs de temps à autre tout ça
pour dire que le poème de la
vérification des intelligences
artificielles c'est un problème qui est
extrêmement difficile et vérifier ligne
à ligne s'avère très qui ne marche
absolument pas ce qu'il faut bas il faut
faire de la recherche ou encore dessus
mais typiquement sur l'écriture de code
il ya énormément de recherches et de
progrès qui ont été faits notamment dans
ce qu'on appelle la spécification des
codes c'est à dire essayer d'écrire dans
le code
ce qu'on veut que le code veut faire et
demandé un algorithme de vérification de
vérifier que le code satisfait bien
c'est différentes spécifications est
clairement pour l'intelligence
artificielle il va falloir y avoir
énormément de systèmes de vérification
mais également beaucoup de systèmes de
tolérance aux fautes puisque
lorsqu'on a une intelligence
artificielle qui se copie colle à
travers internet
mais avoir des petits bugs qui vont
apparaître par ci par là et il va
falloir que l'intelligence artificielle
continue à avoir une bonne fonction
objectifs malgré le fait que lorsqu'elle
se duplique il y à des erreurs de copies
qui vont avoir lieu j'espère que vous
avez aimé cette vidéo la pression va
revenir encore sur la vidéo de la
semaine dernière puisqu'une comment je
vais le commenter et le des bunkers
pourrait dire si vous avez cet épisode
penser à le lac et à le commenter à le
partager pour savourer un bon époque
pendant que les futurs épisodes merci
petit port power dont et j'espère que
vous serez là la prochaine fois le
leader il faudra